uh welcome Nana congratulations that was
a really fine win uh well please tell me
how do you feel in Saint Louis by the
way what time did you wake up today
today it was Improvement I woke up at 4
30 I think
what was yesterday 3 30. did you manage
to sleep a little bit before the game
yeah okay so that's that was an
improvement yeah before the game I'm
trying to to get some sleep one hour
sleep maybe yeah otherwise it's it's
impossible okay so let's have a look at
the at your game it was a very
interesting opening and I think yeah I
don't know if you remember you already
played this line against Elena danilan
yeah yeah I usually play this line time
to time yeah so at critical moment I
think it was in exactly in this position
when she took Bishop D3 I think um what
did you think she was supposed to be she
should have played Bishop F3 I think
Bishop F3 Bishop F3 and he takes it
three
uh if takes E3 Knight D3 Knight D3
Queen D3
Bishop B7
Rook B8
and here yeah I was thinking where to go
with the special on F3 or I think on if
trip because yeah yeah
and here on black has I think very
interesting options like playing C4 with
idea Bishop C5 uh Rook d8 yeah
um so I think
objectively it must be equal because I
have Bishop D force it takes b38xp3 yeah
yes the computer actually agrees with
you by the way it's sorry to interrupt
you our mirror but uh we do YouTubers
draw right so right here I wanted to ask
you if you were calculating this move
because now that I look at this line the
computer offers Queen S3 yes maybe yes
and what about Knight C2 Queen goes
where Queen NATO you know this is not
the line that's it's probably easy to
calculate this is really I mean strange
this computer evaluation sometimes is
really confusing I don't know no of
course the line that you offered is more
human than I agree with you you know
this was probably the best continuation
for black so let's have a look after
Bishop j3 yeah after Rook D1 I already
liked my position very much and and yeah
when she went to Bishop A6 it takes D4
please continue
after Knight D4 I thought my position is
already winning here because my pieces
are very active
Knight F5 is a threat so yeah but there
was so many options for me to how to I
mean how to win the game that I was
calculating Then I then I saw and I was
very low on time and finally I managed
to convert this Advantage actually and
as you mentioned that the most difficult
thing for her in this position would be
that there are so many options do you
find it difficult from time to time
because your eyes are looking everywhere
yes because I was calculating I missed
so many lines and yeah finally I think I
I I've chosen the which was the simplest
I just took exchange and then yeah
converts to the Simplicity
um Nana this is your third time that you
play the sound list so you played every
Edition so I well welcome back of course
so tell us a little bit why do you like
this tournament
yeah I mean uh here I feel really
special because everybody it feels like
everybody loves and respects our game
and yeah it's always very pleasant for
me to come here and play
so you're certainly trying to do your
best and well this question which
doesn't have to do anything with chess
well of course everyone is dressing
really elegantly we have a dress code
but I was thinking Hmm okay how many
shoes do you have how many pair of shoes
do you have
such a question
actually
when I came when I came from home I had
three pairs of shoes but then I went to
Germany I played the tournament in
Germany and there I was three more so
then I went to Nicosia and then I also
bought some more so some seven pairs of
shoes so I was not so off you know we
describing at home how many let's say 20
30. I mean yeah many more
yes I just wanted to to ask a fun
question because I think it's it's uh
well we have so many beautiful images
and like all the players are very
elegant so thank you very much Nana We
Wish You A lot of success in this
tournament and well hope to see you
again thank you maybe yes sir has a
question no just our congratulations a
very very nice Victory to get today we
really liked the harmony of your
attacking forces so continue absolutely
continue good play
and our result